Valerian roster Mania is beginning to
simmer down and we now have a better
idea of what teams are going to look
like when the VCT returns one team in
particular has finalized his roster and
Gamers we just may have a super team on
our hands
hey guys before we get into the video we
have to remind you as always to hit the
like button the Subscribe button and to
ring that notification Bell if you do I
will get a sweatshirt with your name on
it so instead of I love my Mom it's I
love your name
that's a lot of money but we're gonna do
it it is that time folks as that time
with balanced roster shake-ups continue
to happen and God has cursed me to never
have a good night's sleep well what's
keeping you up at night Liz well besides
my crippling anxiety and self-hatred
it's the fact that these roster shakeups
continue to happen who was going where
what will the teams look like will there
be a super team will it be Sentinels or
will it be cloud nine now we've known
for a bit that Cloud9 blue needs some
people on its team as you can tell they
would need two players a coach and
assistant coach an analyst one thing
that roster Mania has brought us is a
plethora of free agents for partner
programs to choose from there were tons
of rumors but nothing was definitive and
then October 17th came around we got a
video that featured three of the players
we knew were staying zeppa vanity and
leaf and then well I'll just let the
rest play internationally known as the
greatest of all time
the man
[Music]
the myth
the goat
[Applause]
s
[Music]
[Applause]
a slope he wants to play close to the
wall
you've got to be kidding me
I hope mango did not hear me call that
guy the goat
Layton last but certainly not least
making his return to Cloud9 it's Celsius
[Music]
[Applause]
no YouTube if you listen closely you can
hear my co-worker now I'm across and AKA
our resident Cloud9 super fans screaming
for Joy because well yeah damn so like
the video says at the end zelsus and yay
are joining us players while MCE and Q
perch are joining us staff I do not
think I need to introduce yay or zelsus
to you but in case you forgot let me
introduce yay first gay was on optic yes
the Masters winning champions finalist
optic and is considered by many to be
not only the best opera in the world one
of the most mechanically gifted players
in the world so good against success
excuse me yay I'll let the comment
section fit about that one don't come
into my DMs zelcis actually has had a
history with Cloud9 before he was a part
of their CS go team a while back and now
he's returned home the name zelsus is
ringing a bell he was a part of version
one and then was a high profile signing
for Sentinels for their lcq that is high
profile of shroud but you catch my drift
and now MC
the guard father we've known each other
many years but this is the first time we
ever came to the council I knew that MCE
was the go-to coach of the guard that
helped bring one of my favorite teams to
the Forefront of the VCT what you guys
might not know is that MCE being here
with this team in Cloud9 is actually a
bit of a reunion in the Cs go
competitive scene once upon a time there
was a little team known as chaos Esports
MC at what point was a coach of that
team well who did he coach along with
others zeppa vanity and leaf so Cloud9
for all of UCS go enjoyers is a fit of a
throwback considering that almost half
of this team existed in a different game
in 2020. I would be remiss if I did not
mention Cooper as Anders wrote on
Twitter C9 picking up cupert is the most
underrated part of their signing every
known as the roster in MC our Top Flight
but slotting in an assistant coach
analyst that can legitimately six man is
a great way to help shoulder the
presumably immense cost of the rest of
the squad Qbert also recently worked
with MCE as an analyst for Champion
against lcq so what is Cloud9 Blue's
potential well you have some of the most
mechanically gifted players and insane
staff a wise igl odds are looking pretty
good I do have pretty high expectations
set for Cloud9 considering that anyone
on that team is a huge get and they have
managed to gather all of them together
on one team so that's promising but you
also have to count in the fact that
other teams like Sentinels for example
are also creating super teams with
people of familiar mechanical prowess
coaching Etc and this is essentially a
brand new start with VCT it will take
time for things to settle
in this case it's just a matter of who
will adopt and settle faster so that is
Cloud9 blue one of valoran's partnered
teams in the Americas
but actually might not have happened
according to slasher on Hugo's stream G2
was actually supposed to have a spot in
the Americas but after the whole Andrew
take Carlos Scandal Cloud9 took that
spot I found out that Cloud9 was
actually the final team on the bubble
really they almost didn't get it Source
tells me that Cloud9 replaced G2 not EG
wow a quick tldr of that is that g2's
Carlos posted a video of him partying
with controversial internet celebrity
Andrew Tate there was a lot of outcry to
the point where G2 suspended Carlos and
then days later Carlos posted a video
announcing that he was no longer CEO Rye
even punished Carlos for his actions so
apparently as a result of Carlos posting
that initial video G2 not only lost the
spot but created an opportunity for
Cloud9 to join the League this
contradicts a previous report that
Leviathan was quote likely to have the
spot but no sort of confirmation has
been given from Riot so at this point it
is all speculation any sort of League
without this super Mecca organization
Cloud9 is a little bit weird but for
being honest this whole partner program
process has been weird thus far and thus
dear viewer ends the tale of how
cloud9's super team came together we
will have to wait and see how everyone
performs at the kickoff tournament in
Sao Paulo Brazil to which if anyone
wants to send me I am taking donations
I love donuts yeah I think my local
grocery store I saw they were selling uh
apple cider donuts which they do during
fall it's like my favorite thing now
since I live alone I could buy as many
as I want so I bought them
they're expensive I realized my family
didn't buy them all the time but